scenes of Destruction in India's
Northeastern Manipur State
long-running tensions between the
majority Mayte community and tribal
groups has flared into violence
the unrest was triggered by a Court
ruling recommending that the Mayte
should be labeled a scheduled tribe
which would Grant special job quotas and
subsidized education
other tribal groups are opposed to this
the tribal groups fear that this would
be an uneven uh benefit given to a
community that has otherwise enjoyed a
lot of privilege enjoyed this proportion
privileges in a state where they
dominate the Legislative Assembly where
they historically have had been
empowered an influx of refugees after
the coup in neighboring Myanmar has
added to the tension there's been a kind
of a very concerted campaign that's been
carried out about uh tribal groups
particularly the cookies and the nagas
being illegal immigrants and how they're
encroaching land and forming these uh
illegal you know Villages and in fact
there have been invictions as well that
have been carried out
the Indian army has been called in to
restore calm thousands of people have
also been moved to safer locations the
state's chief minister has appealed for
calm saying the fighting has been caused
by a misunderstanding we are having
altogether 35 community
since time immemorial in the state of
Manipur the incident which was taken
place yesterday was due to
misunderstanding and some communication
gap and now everything has been settled
and will be
normalized very shoot
mobile internet has been shut down for
five days and the state government has
issued a shoot at site order to enforce
a curfew
India's Army says it's brought the
situation under control and is
continuing to work to restore normalcy
Felix Noir Al Jazeera